bernie sanders and aoc
get just two percent each and twenty
twenty four iowa democratic caucuses
poll without biting that's a newsweek
story okay so uh even though they're a
distant long shot and a new survey of
iowa
democratic national presidential
caucuses that does not include
president joe biden the poll released
monday by republican firm victory
insights
shows both progressive lawmakers with
two percent support each
vice president kamala harris is the
clear front runner at 28 percent
with secretary of transportation pete
puduch following at 15
and former first lady michelle obama at
12 undecided was the second most popular
choice
overall at 16 with five percent saying
they would vote for someone else biden
was far and away
the top choice when he was including the
poll with 63
support the poll would was conducted
over the phone among 600 iowa democrats
on april 8th thoughts
you know um
it just you know ignorance is bliss
that's for sure
uh to live in a world where people are
gonna feed into your victimhood
mentality
your the world's against me mentality um
it's an easy life to live because you
could just sit there and blame everybody
for your
for your uh for your uh misfortunes or
for your bad
your bad decision making uh and then
when you have somebody with
12.1 million views i mean um 12.1
million followers
um that can that can say yes you're
right you're a victim
uh and make you know actually i'm not
surprised
i'm i'm i'm uh disappointed in people's
idiocy
but i'm not surprised that she's getting
that much that much clout because
uh most of america or not most i'm sorry
let me retract that
a lot of americans are self-pity type of
people
they believe in uh uh institutional
racism they believe that the
there's a government out to get them
which i don't believe any of that
[ __ ] i just don't it just
you know uh and maybe it's because i've
lived through it you know i'm a hispanic
immigrant
for and mexico i actually come from one
of the most cartel war-torn parts of
mexico
and uh i dropped out of high school i
was incarcerated 13 years ago and here i
am sitting in front of you
uh and nobody gave me anything we were
never on government assistance my mom
was a single mom
taking care of two kids she took care of
me alejandro uh
working two jobs she sold tequila and
she was doing and she was a waitress
never my mom didn't know what government
assistant was so therefore
we survived that and here i am uh as a
top one percent income earner of america
with no help from the government ever so
i just don't i can't
it's very hard for me for me to buy in
well you know a lot of people i
understand if you're you know second
generation wealth how you can say well
you were born in some money i get that
but we were not born into money meaning
now we're both part of the one percent
uh thanks to your help and your coaching
so
what i'm getting at is that if you put
yourself in the right environment and
put yourself around the right people
that you're gonna win i just but a lot
of people are gonna buy into there's no
opportunities if you can't find
opportunities in america where the hell
else are you gonna find them you're
screwed
this is this is people come here migrate
here if i'm almost thinking the number
was 91
91 million people come here a year
either passing through or staying here
they're coming here i mean if people are
trying to are dying on the way up
from from the south of the border to get
here there's a reason why they're doing
that
nobody's migrating to china nobody's
migrating to germany nobody's they're
migrating here
so if you can't as an american find an
opportunity in america
what the hell are you going to do with
your life we are the beacon of
capitalism
enterprise and entrepreneurship and if
you can't do it here you're screwed
and i'm glad that you know elon musk is
calling himself the emperor of mars
because that's the only other place you
can go
well i mean you can't do it here where
the hell else are you gonna do it
so maybe let me ask you a different
question by the way uh aoc is born
october 13th
i'm very surprised she's a libra because
we're five days apart she's 13 i'm 18.
right but she's born october 13th
1989 she is 31 years old
four years from now she'll be 35 years
old
it's the age to be able to join
president the way they're doing the math
apparently if
she is in this poll that means she is
eligible to run if she chose to
but this is more important more
importantly i think the question let's
say
okay let's run a poll let's run a poll
let's run a po i'm actually curious with
everybody here that's watching this
let's run a poll okay how likely
is it that in the next 40 years
aoc who's only 31 today in the next 40
years she's 71.
how many elections does she have in the
next four years 10 shots
10 shots okay well if it's a two-term
you know all that other stuff fine but
let's just say she's got 10 shots right
what is the likelihood of aoc in the
next 40 years
to be the president of united states
next 40 years
likelihood of winning
give me a percentage i i i'm kind of i'm
kind of split on the nematode whitepap
because
i think that we're going in such a in
such a bad direction right now under the
leadership that we have right now
and it's just obvious this is not an
opinion it's mathematical facts
that we're pushing so hard that we're
realizing i think americans some amer
majority americans are realizing
elon musk are the best the left they're
losing the middle right
so i think we're pushing so hard on one
side the left is losing the middle
losing the middle elon must quoted that
he's literally
he tweeted that so he i think that
there's two parts to it if if
they don't push hard enough there's a
maybe 80 chance
but if they push too hard people are
gonna realize that we're under really
bad leadership like i don't think they
realize that right now
right so once once they realize that
we're losing all battles
at the border with with um global trade
with the economy with the stock i mean
we're losing every battle right
america is losing every battle and you
don't have to agree with it look at the
numbers if you don't know greece because
you don't look at the numbers
uh if they push hard enough i think
people are going to wake up and we're
going to rebound from this on the hard
way on the other side
um so but if if they still people are
still not even dumb and they're not
realizing how bad they're being affected
then yeah there's a 80
chance she'll be president next 40 years
unfortunately give me a percentage
five percent no because
wow you sold me on the idea that victims
are the best recruiters you have hands
down you started my fault
you said victims are the best recruiters
yep and i'm like you're right so i think
that she's going to be 80 percent
eddie unbelievable what do you think
yeah well shout out to ricky he's
passionate he's fired up he's um
he's really going in i don't think he's
a fan of aoc i don't know if you can
tell that so uh 80
i think is aggressive bro um
i'm thinking nobody thought trump was
gonna be president look at that
look let's talk about track record here
she might not even be 35 by the time the
election comes up so i think it's just
before i get to my first years in the
next four years yeah but let me just
okay well let me just you know you you
you went on a diatribe here let me give
my diatribe and then
we go okay and then i'll go look she
hasn't done [ __ ] in her career
okay she's a representative when's the
last time a senator other than barack
obama has been elected
president okay kennedy i don't know who
else so a representative she's big in
new york people in new york like her
that's great
you gotta win something bigger than your
district to actually become president so
look we're talking four years away and
she might not even be eligible
to even run at that point i think we're
way ahead of schedule we're even
talking about her uh let's get through
let's get through the midterms yeah i
don't think she's
how do you think i don't think she's
anywhere near qualified whatsoever
hey player let me talk here bro i'll put
down another button bro
i'll go down another [ __ ] button but
that doesn't make sense what you're
saying though
i don't think she's qualified to even
consider running whatsoever and i don't
think she's guys
one particular and the other one wasn't
even a senator listen we've already seen
it happen
all right all right go ahead so um
your fans need to hear from you too
exactly listen it's way too early to
even suggest she's pulling at two
percent let's
if she's fun she gets the you know like
you still have an answer to the question
the likelihood that she would become
president yeah i'll give her 10
that's high by the way just so you know
just the fact that you're saying 10
percent
i'm high at 10 ricardo's throwing 80.
and he's reasonable what i'm saying to
you was just the fact that you think
in the next 40 40 years i get that what
i'm trying to tell you is it's a real
conversation
that's what i'm saying like it is real
yeah you understand it is that name
right okay so now let me give you the
follow-up question that's the that's
where
i've been trying to get into for this
entire time today
is 46 2046.
okay today's 2046. your president
is aoc what does america look like go
there
by the way 2046 is 25 years from now
she is only 56 years old what does
america look like well
let me just let's establish what her
life looks like okay before we can go to
america number one she's single she's a
waitress she hasn't made any money
she hasn't done anything in her career i
just told you 25 years ago okay exactly
so
at that point yeah she would
presumably be married have some kids
um potentially her outlook on life would
change not everything is stagnant things
change
she might develop her views the world
might be a different place
so give people a little credit to the
fact that their
perspectives might change you weren't
always a capitalist
you weren't always anti-a democrat you
were
reasonable at some point i presume i'm
not reasonable now
no i'd say more you're literally let me
have a little question let me ask you a
question
is the the the argument of socialism
reasonable
i don't i don't is the argument on
socialism reasonable
is the argument reasonable or is the
concept reasonable whatever
any argument is reasonable no no having
a having a debate is
a person to establish what the fact is a
person who believes in
like i can see a democrat switch into
independent like john stasso went from
hey i'm the guy that's exposing all
these businesses finally one day i'm
like what the hell am i doing i'm
helping consumer affairs
more than i am small business owners and
i'm making fun of these guys and they're
losing their businesses
there's no way i'm going to do this i'm
going to be a libertarian he flips but
he went from a
center left john f kennedy type of a
democrat to what a libertarian
he didn't flip to be a republican right
what is the likelihood
of aoc changing that much
philosophically the next 24 years well
i'll tell you if she has any
chances of to answer your question
specifically becoming the president for
the masses
she better flip and fight i don't think
you're i don't she's not going to win
being that far left wait
wait she's not wait she's not going to
win being that far left
correct okay i have a whole different
view on this but ricky i want to go to
you
you still haven't answered my question
for me i asked you
if 20 45
aoc is the press 2046 aoc's the
president
she's 55 56 years old what does america
look like i'll tell you we'll have a lot
of flippin debt
more than whatever we have now what else
will america look like no
as far as they're going to come after
ricky's 40 guns but but first of all
before i continue to say are you picking
up ricky's audio i want to make sure
that mike is picking up his own
so so to be to be to be to be
show your point real quick and then i'll
go to pbd's question
no she's not going to change maxine
waters hasn't changed nancy pelosi
hasn't changed
bernie sanders hasn't changed these
people have not changed they don't these
people don't change because they have to
follow a narrative
okay that's the only way they could win
the votes because they have to follow
the narrative even if
by the way she said that at the border
the crisis that we have at the border
right now even though it's worse than
when we had it with trump
she said that it had to do with climate
change
that's literally what she said so so she
has to she's going to continue with her
narrative because that's only what she's
going to continue to get voted in
she needs to vote the the the victims
need to keep voting hurting
but what do we look like as a country
you have a you have aoc as a president
we're definitely going to have our
debt's going to be through what you said
adam
uh def definitely will not have any guns
definitely won't have any guns uh she's
gonna run out all the capitalists and
all the business owners out of the
country
they'll end up in another country uh and
uh and the
company we're gonna go into it will be
uh she stays around long enough these
ideas stay wrong long enough and by the
way
it's anybody if you're listening to this
and you think this cannot happen to
america you are naive
the world has said has said seven world
powers pat
america is a seventh world power so rome
fell and
there was a one point that there was
there was a satan that said that the sun
never set on the roman empire
rome fell babylon fell great britain
fell all these countries have fought
every what goes up must come down so to
believe
and sit here and listen to us and say oh
that'll never happen here you are
literally naive you did not pay
attention history guys have never picked
up a history book
but yeah would be we'd be destroyed as a
country and there would be another
america somewhere else because would we
though so so let's go there
let's go there and let's go there and
say she and if she wins she's not going
to be a one-term president she'll be a
two-term
should be two-term two-term because okay
let's but let's speculate this is all
purely speculation
what happens afterwards so do so does it
push back so far that do we go back to
being far right
what is america after aoc can you
recover even if you go forward
i don't know let's look at history since
and i think that was a great point you
made about the
empires of civilization every every
eight years the pendulum swings it's a
reason why you go from a reagan to a
bush
to a clinton and you go from a clinton
to a bush and you go from a bush to a
obama and you go from obama to a trump
and a trump to abide in
it's the same old narrative that we've
had even before reagan you had a jimmy
carter and you had a gerald ford
and you had a nixon and you had a lbj
it's the same old theme
and every four years every eight years
that's why a president runs on
change change barack obama ran on change
trump ran on change biden ran on they
gotta get the [ __ ] this uh the orange
monster out of here we gotta change
things
every eight years people run on change
it's the most common theme
ever when it comes to elections so god
forbid an aoc becomes into power
you know somebody who's that ricky
wholeheartedly believes in
will come in and the whole country will
rally around them and say
all right we've had well then let me ask
you let me
what happened can you just turn me up a
little bit let me ask you a different
question here's a different question for
you here's a different question for you
you ever been robbed at gunpoint right
no no
have you yes okay i had a gun pointed at
me not robbed but yeah we had a gun
pointed
out okay i've had a gun pointed at me
yeah okay
okay so all three of us now do you think
what's the likelihood of you having uh
somebody robbing you at gunpoint
it's like the likelihood between now and
the day you died for ricky
no no foreign a lot higher than me
between now and your end of days what's
the likelihood of that happening is my
shirt open or no
give me any percentage one percent one
percent okay fair enough okay
uh what's the likelihood of
uh you getting into a terrible car
accident
25 you i don't think so
no i think it's it's my uber driver's
drunk person
yeah it's one percent what's the two
percent what's the likelihood
of a uh empire
fallen america fallen what's the
likelihood of an empire falling
pretty damn high yeah really i'm asking
you
what do you think 20 okay you say what
i'd say at least 40 to 50 okay i think
it's inevitable it's just a matter of is
it 100 years from now 500 years from a
thousand
i think it's gonna i think it's a
hundred percent if you ask me yes
because the five million
infinity i think it's just it's
eventually gonna fall right
so what is really the responsibilities
of the citizen
of that era of that era what is our
responsibility
the responsibility of the citizens of
our era
today 2021 is to make sure this
generation is not the one that falls
right neither next or the following
because we have what kids
grandkids so our job is to keep that
going for
two more generations it's why we have to
care about it so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye